focus de l'été avec koh lanta alors
comment tu as énormément déçu à la fois
pour sa préparation yardi à la fois pour
ses règles très compliqué à la fois pour
son casting trop télé réalité à la fois
pour ses tricheries tous trop fréquentes
bref ça a été une année très très
compliqué petit récap on en parle juste
après
cette année on a eu droit à une saison
colons d'arras est folle au fond de voir
une candidate tenter faire du feu avec
ses cheveux tout simplement comme le
cheveu ça brûle très très vite ça va
prendre feu mais tous la jeune et jolie
j'ai l'air tandis que dix minutes plus
tard un autre aventurier faisait lui
aussi du feu
mais en foot on savait plus trop ce
qu'on gardait corde
[Musique]
après l'effort le réconfort l'horizon
sorti la grosse barback et ses amis
luana dans tous ses états myskina régime
est défié l'otan faisait pas chaud non
mais toi
désolé avec le billet rempli les rouges
étaient prêts à se mettre au lit
tranquillou du doubs on va vous donner à
toi espère surtout qui va pas tarder à
mon ami je pense pas que ça éclate cette
news sauf que trois minutes plus tard
c'est l'horreur
bombay et candidats ont commencé une
épreuve de guidage les yeux bandés où il
était plutôt calme top avance avance
avance va l'avoir et il n'aura pas fallu
longtemps pour être plus calmes du tout
en parlant de communication il ya une
petite incompréhension entre les jeunes
on n'est pas sûr d'avoir tout compris je
n'ai pas compris comprend pas que c'est
pas compris je dois mourir je comprends
pas que t'es pas compris bah oui mais
j'ai pas compris cette fois ci je n'ai
pas bougé parce qu'on avait que moi t'as
pas compris en fait mais heureusement
conseil se sont tous mis d'accord et
celle qui s'est encore faite éliminée
avec seulement 1,75 pour cent des voix
c'est encore anne hidalgo
arrivé la saison 2 les gens étaient très
attractives la vacance oui c'était
tourner du côté de ta ta ta ta ta vous
vous rêvez que l'on tape plus encore oui
c'est si je regarde moi j'ai pas regardé
la dernière
vous êtes fan ah oui ou non ces six mois
c'est vraiment le genre d'émission c'est
pile poil je suis pas la cible c'est
votre poème préféré oui je crois ouais
mais c'est très bien il en faut attendez
que j'ai demandé les notamment démontré
fait avec deux semaines pour ces dames
nc à lens a compris c'est incroyable
c'est fou ça un pascal lacoste et bien
écoutez moi j'ai mis la note de deux
ânes on ne veut pas un générique
s'arrête plus belle la vie des trucs qui
sont bien quand même pas mal arrêtez koh
lanta je ne peux plus ses missions et
les visas soit 11 2 wii nommé même jour
à un principe arrêté arrêté koh lanta
j'en ai marre je trouve qu'à plus de
haut des bus c'est chouette aujourd'hui
je trouve qu'il ya plus l'âme de koh
lanta voilà c'est ses petits alors
attention c'est la télé réalité je ne
critique pas que la télé réalité ne
t'énerve pas magani
adorable avec moi me dit s'agit
jeu 34e voilà il ya trop d'histoires il
ya de la triche mais je trouve que ça a
perdu son âme et bonne foi là moi je me
fais chier alors koh-lanta d'ailleurs je
le regarde plus la stime pour vos
mauvais casting trop dribbler casting
trop de la tricherie
c'est plus comme avant en collant tâches
ou alors on a passé un cap pense qu'il
faut tourner la caméra
peut dire avant ça peut être
voila je viens de voir on va citer
uniqlo et camille va bien merci
ludivine ah bah écoutez moi je monte un
petit peu bah oui une fois de plus ce
que diront les biens pour dames mais oui
ben non voilà moi j'aimais le programme
jusqu'à la première saison theora
j'étais super fan crête longtemps parce
qu'on avait encore des vrais aventuriers
on avait des personnes qui étaient
vraiment ça qui était vierge en fait de
tout téléréalité et de tout ce que ça
comporte le vrai compte maintenant
laisser nancy tellement scénarisé tout
tout est porté en fait tout est fait
pour nous faire croire qu'on regarde de
latérite et on a totalement oublié
l'esprit aventure et où après les années
hubert y délivre on est tous moi
j'allais en plus ça c'est vrai aussi par
la saison des légendes quand on a
découvert qu'ils me oui
largement fournis en nourriture oui
c'était compliqué on a on a du magnéto
allons-y regardez nous avons appris et
nous avons eu la confirmation qu à
plusieurs reprises vous avez demandé à
des pêcheurs qui passaient au large de
la nourriture et que plusieurs fois on
vous a apporté à manger c'est un
comportement déloyal
qui constitue un manquement à l'éthique
aux règles de koh lanta il y aura
sanction vous allez directement
rejoindre la résidence du jury final
pour vous koh lanta se termine
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors
eh ouais à manger une seule fois un
steak frites et des légumes claude
l'orangeade ça mes filles auraient mangé
chaud cola pepsi cola fromage pâtes et
pizzas et des dîners anniversaire avec
le chaland tout est tous les trois jours
tous les trois jours et d'après parisien
le couple a été particulièrement au spi
hospitalier en ouvrant ses portes et
surtout sa cuisine ou à l'ensemble
l'équipe de tf1 donc c'est quand même un
vrai problème comme sidi s'était tourné
à tahiti t é té i télé et écrire en
théorie les clins d'oeil va donc c'était
et puis il faut savoir que la bac quand
vous êtes sur un îlot en face il ya tout
il ya des hôtels est un succès il ya une
tentation mais n'ont jamais servi c'est
dommage et vous comment vous mettez moi
j'ai mis 5 je déplore le manque
d'innovation moi je prends d'autres
exemples parce que c'est dans tous les
pays c'est survive or dans beaucoup
d'autres pays s'appelle survivor koh
lanta notamment par exemple en grèce il
ya quelques années en grèce ils ont eu
une idée de concept pour changer un
petit peu parce que les gens se lassait
c'était de fusionner avec la turquie à
côté donc en fait y avait une équipe
grecque contre une équipe turque et un
présentateur ya qu un présentateur turc
et ça a cartonné parce que ça on a
apporté quelque chose de nouveau donc je
pense que koh lanta l'idée de base est
influente d'intervilles ouais on
pourrait vous pourrez trouver des choses
pas chères afin que les choses évoluent
parce que là vingt saisons il ya eu
quelques petites idées mais franchement
ça justement ils n'ont pas eu tort de
vouloir absolument
renouveler sans générer de koh lanta
c'est quoi finalement juste des gens qui
sont à peu près normaux voies larges et
graves déclarent qu'ils sont là pour
vivre une aventure la forte pas manger
ou peu pendant 40 jours et elle quand ça
les plus résistants pourquoi rajouter un
petit mot doux
amer
en fait finalement tout ça c'est des pas
au changement c'est pas un changement de
base du concept c'est ça le problème
parce que vingt saisons là soit on prend
un risque soit on s'éteint soit on
revient aux basiques
envers musique deckers
je n'en peux plus de cette émission de
désespérer
moi je rêve de quelque chose j'ai fait
ça
devienne un château et qu'à la place de
leurs pagnes il est des smokings et des
robes longues alors on garderait des
épreuves l'adresse mail épreuve
l'adresse rehavam avec quelques
cuillères utilise mange-t-on sa
marmelade ou sa confiture il a vu
comment met-on correctement manger une
salade
hésitant une coupe à champagne où une
fuite a chanté vitamine c et voilà je
suis non je remets arte le concept
nature
je sais pas j'espère que c'est pas
contagieux mais le nom et concept
voilà
vous n'avez pas des aventuriers les gens
qui le voilà qui se jaugent à l'idée
qu'il veut forcément quand même des rois
et les reines à windows et office et son
égérie sur ce à quoi
ils sont en survie c'est ça
la bille et
magali oui moi je mets 8 parce que je
vous trouve très méchant parce que c'est
une émission qui est précurseur de plein
de choses
arrête de regarder les aventures et leur
date vous les aventuriers par exemple
sur w9 les
capelains démission aujourd'hui sur dans
la télé jean
caméra cachée ce pas aussi une caméra
cachée et speedy
basket c'est le but du mans
découpez la pâte en émissions qui sont
inspirés de koh lanta aujourd'hui il ya
donc ces canards ne m'arrête inspiration
veut dire quoi alors l'environnement pas
laisser passer ça
non mais ces gens me voient pas pourquoi
tu fais ça avec des traits d'une liste
de plus de temps allez-y photo sk bon
excusez moi je déteste cette émission
alors moi je me trouve bien fait pour
toi alors non
moi je déteste pas tout mais pour le
coup j'ai alors oui au début j'ai bien
aimé par tous déjà la date ça va passer
le vendredi donc voilà on arrive à
accrocher généralement le vendredi 200
pompiers donc voila tu dis je reste
aujourd'hui voilà on s'ennuie pardon et
maintenant le mardi je trouve que c'est
ça ne va pas durer et correctement oui
excusez moi mon france ont châtié
parfois je m'en excuse un
marchand lui pas bas
non
je suis pas prête à regarder koh lanta
le mardi je trouve que c'est trop
redondant je trouve qu'il ya trop de
denis brogniart pourquoi pas de changer
d'animateur
possible aucun cas
il est très bien oui mais d'accord mais
je crois qu'aujourd'hui alors que cela
il a animé depuis début sauf une saison
la première qui était représenté par un
ver et sabine secours n'ont pas pu
avaler mais quand il est très facile
albert aurions eu mais orgueilleux
compétiteurs mission alors oui oui non
pourquoi pas changer d'armé temps mais
j'ai rien contre denis brogniart mais
voilà un peu de changements et surtout
du repos et là je pense qu'il faut
arrêter koh lanta pendant il ya encore
une saison khiari et après ils vont la
reposer là
gros repos voilà c'est no 3 de repos
merci jean minondo nouveaux colons de
tasses en 2000 brogniart ces annonces
ont cherché sa voie c'est qu'on attend
sa voix au
gmi zéro parce que c'est un amour déçu
l'année prochaine je remettrai dit c'est
mon émission préférée du paf c'est une
des seules limites sont qui soit
vraiment familial qu'on peut regarder
sans avoir le risque qui est des choses
qu'ils soient vulgaire etc on regarde
tout temps en famille et mes enfants que
ses paires à ses missions que j'adore
mais là les enfants qui ont pu déjà
vides et que donc je mets 0 et la
prochaine je mettrais d'y aller cette
année non je sanctionne merci zambie
alors et moyennes de koh lanta
oui 3 ou non j'écoute ça ils suivirent
extrêmement sévère